you know it was like a Night at the
Opera Pennsylvania is the state that
gave us the 45th President of the United
States South Korea came to my office
after having gone to North Korea and
seeing Kim jong-un and no it's very
positive now after the meeting you made
you that but now we have to be very nice
because let's see what happens this
should have been handled by the way over
the last thirty years not now
I'm joking about being president for
life a couple of went back don't know
Trump with his dictatorial attitude now
wants to be President for life
fake news I'd love Oprah to win I'd love
to beat Oprah I know her weakness Conner
lamb-lamb the Sham right lamda sham
I hear he's nice-looking I think I'm
better looking than him personally I
like Rick Sacco and I think he's answer
so it had everything jokes check insults
check media outrage check the booing is
getting stronger by the day whenever he
goes out there and whips up like it's a
Mussolini rally yes that's what I said
what are you supposed to say when he's
using these vulgarities to kids
mm-hmm and so the media reacted in this
sweaty frenzy to a speech the rest of us
have pretty much gotten used to by now
what really upset him this Maxine Waters
a very low IQ individual we will impeach
him we will impeach the press but he
hasn't done anything wrong
it doesn't matter we will impeach him
she's a low IQ individual you can't help
now never mind her irrational
accusations she's made about Trump this
is just another sign of racism which is
weird why is calling someone stupid
racist are we all capable of being
stupid I know I can but Brett but Greg
Maxine's a black woman yes you're right
I forgot remember when Trump made fun of
that black candidate or that black TV
couple or that black newscaster
or that black congresswoman or that
black Republican or that black senator
or that black war hero or that black has
been comedian
sorry Trump's an equal-opportunity
roaster no one is safe but my favorite
part when he mocks being presidential
remember I used to how easy it is to be
presidential but you'd all be out of
here right now but you'd be so bored I'm
very presidential ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being here tonight
Rick ciccone will be a great great
congressman thank you very much the walk
I know how dari mocked the formality of
the office but he's being honest he
showed you the manner of a typical
politician and he said That's not me
the implication what good are you beyond
such platitudes if you're not killing
terrorists creating jobs reducing a
nuclear threat and that's the point the
difference between Trump and others the
tasteful charade of political lifers
isn't part of his vocabulary and so you
you are absolutely right to say that
he's vulgar but what are you gonna do
when the public says so what wrap it up
we'll take it